Okay.
We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P here is a very important voicemail
that I receive.
Take a listen to this.
Um, I just, uh, you know, I'm tired of hearing
this, uh, narrative that Donald Trump isn't
going to debate Bernie, uh, because either
a, he's scared of Bernie or B, he just feels
like he doesn't have to debate Bernie and
I just want to put that to rest because, uh,
that would be seeding a platform for Bernie
to just say whatever he wants about Donald
Trump to the American people in a crucial
election without Donald Trump there.
Just say his peace for the American people.
And I think that would just be that that would
be devastating to Trump's chances to win in
2020.
And he knows it and I'm sure people on his
campaign though.
Yeah, so you're not wrong.
In general, I think the most likely scenario
is Trump will plan to debate is the eventual
democratic nominee.
There's a couple of things there.
One, you're assuming that if Trump doesn't
debate that Bernie is just given 90 minutes
to say whatever he wants and answer questions.
It would be unprecedented.
It would be uncharted territory that one of
the major candidates of the two parties says,
I'm simply not going to do debates.
So for me, it's not a guarantee that Bernie
just gets time to do whatever he wants.
That's a question Mark.
The thing that is coming up more and more
is that if you believe that Donald Trump is
declining cognitively, there is a question
Mark about whether Donald Trump would be able
to handle a 90 minute debate with one other
candidate in August or September or even October
when if you believe Trump is deteriorating
cognitively, he would presumably be more deteriorated.
Again, there's a number of different arguments.
I don't think that Trump would not go to the
debates because he's scared of Bernie.
I agree with you.
I think there's other stories that are taking
place and of course I don't know that you're
right that Trump would suffer.
Even if Bernie gets to just say what he wants
for 90 minutes, Trump can win without appealing
to people who like Bernie, right?
I mean Trump, Donald Trump lost the popular
vote in 2016 one electorally, he can do it
again just by firing up his own base and saying
the debates are rigged.
I'm not going, is not guaranteed to hurt him.
That may actually resonate with enough of
his supporters that he could win again.
But you are right.
The most likely scenario is Trump shows up
at the debates.
Today on the bonus show, we will talk about
the new found focus on helicopter safety that
has surfaced since the tragic death of Kobe
Bryant.
We are also going to talk about a man who
was, uh, handcuffed and in a police cruiser
and yet was shot and killed.
How did that happen?
We will discuss and we will also talk about
another one of these hilarious, wealthy NIMBY,
not in my backyard type stories.
This one is out of Florida.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Don't miss it.
Sign up for a
membership@joinedpacmandotcomtogetinstantaccessorbecomeapatronatthefivedollarorgreaterlevelatpatrion.com
slash David Pakman show.
Lastly, one more reminder.
Sunday, the David Pakman show birthday special.
It's my birthday on Sunday.
We're doing a huge membership blowout.
If you want to be notified, just get on our
newsletter mailing list.
Okay.
David pakman.com you'll see a place in the
upper right.
You type in your email address and then on
Sunday you'll get an email with instructions
on how to take advantage of this discount.
Uh, the emails are flooding in.
People concerned that I will be indicted because
the discount is so huge.
It could be illegal on the West coast and,
uh, we are retaining counsel or that we, I
want to do this
even if it puts me at risk with prison time.
I get access to that special by getting on
our mailing list, the David pakman.com talk
to you on the bonus show in near minute, the
David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].